straight ahead
on lawn crime daily attorney jeff storms
joins us to discuss the dante wright
case
as a former officer stands charged with
shooting and killing the 20 year old
this officer pulled aimed and
shot her firearm in practice so don't
tell us
it's an accident plus our legal analysis
on possible appeals for derrick chauvin
in the murder of george floyd i do think
it will hit the supreme court
plus heartbreak a car and a gun
everything you need to know about the
upcoming trial of joshua aid
and how lady gaga's frenchies helped
capture five members of an alleged
underground dog napping ring
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer
co-host terry austin is off the training
records for a former police officer
charged
in the death of a 20 year old minnesota
man are now coming under fire
dante wright was shot and killed by
police during a traffic stop
earlier this month now former officer
kim potter
is charged with second-degree
manslaughter she allegedly mistakenly
used her gun
instead of a taser to subdue right as
they tried to arrest him
the 26 year old veteran of the force was
acting as a training officer
but her newly released service file
shows few details about her own training
history
she has a bachelor's in criminal justice
and underwent special law enforcement
training in 1995
brooklyn center officials have not said
whether any materials including
commendations or principle
have not yet been made public
i'm joined now by civil rights attorney
jeff storms who represents dante
wright's family
jeff let's get right to the heart of
this what do you say to those that say
former officer potter was doing her job
and just really made
a really bad accident or mistake
yeah to say that is nonsense
um the difference between a firearm and
a taser
are legion there are many differences
they look differently you carry one on
your dominant side meaning your sidearm
is on your dominant side to protect
against
an accidental draw you are your taser on
your weak side
uh you know they look differently they
feel differently uh you're trained
over and over again not to make this
mistake
and so when we look at the facts of this
case
we're going to see that this officer
officer potter
had to engage in numerous intentional
acts
to get to the point from where she
removed her sidearm from its holster
and pulled the trigger killing dante
wright
and jeff what do you make of potter's
training background or lack thereof
you know we're early on in the case at
this point and
whether or not uh officer potter was
properly trained is obviously going to
be a critical issue
in the civil litigation with respect to
brooklyn center his own
civil liability so i don't want to
comment prematurely
but what i can say is you know certainly
we should all be asking questions as to
whether or not that training
was enough uh we we have you know dante
wright dead we have an
officer who was training other officers
and you know pulled her sidearm at a
time where it was
unreasonable and unlawful to do so so
certainly they're going to be repeated
questions about training
and you know one of the questions we're
going to have is you know
was she also engaging in training
outside of the department
that's been known to be dangerous and
associated with
other deaths and in particular i'm
talking about the
killology training we've seen around the
country
or warrior training as it's described as
well
so they're gonna be very important
questions we're gonna have to answer
in this case i can see that for sure
thanks jeff and of course wright's death
happened just
miles from the court during the trial a
former minneapolis police officer
derrick chopin
showman will appeal his conviction in
the death of george floyd and some
lawyers think it could go all the way to
the supreme court
angela levy is here to explain why that
could happen
and this was watched of course around
the world and that's not a bad
but it's what happened before and during
the trial
outside of the courtroom that some
lawyers believe could cause
issues on appeal mentioned some of them
believe that this case could end up at
the highest court in the
land members of the jury i understand
you have a verdict
the jury in derrick chauvin's trial
found him guilty on all counts without
asking a single question
jurors heard from dozens of witnesses
and saw videos of george floyd dying
but there are questions about whether
forces outside of the courtroom
impacted the jurors there were images of
civil unrest the police shooting of
dante wright
and comments from congresswoman maxine
waters
about what should happen if there was
not a guilty verdict
this jury should have been sequestered
from day one
before they did openings and i think
that was a mistake on the part of judge
cahill
who did a great job former federal
prosecutor and law and crime legal
analyst gene rossi
agrees with an opinion voiced by
constitutional law expert alan
dershowitz
that chauvin's case will likely end up
at the u.s supreme court
i think the supreme court is salivating
to give some guidance
to judges at the lower levels on how to
conduct
high profile cases rossi likens the
chauvin case to sam
shepards shepard was a doctor in
cleveland whose wife maryland was
murdered in 1954.
shepard said an intruder killed his wife
but he was charged and convicted of her
murder
the u.s supreme court vacated shepherd's
conviction in 1966
citing a carnival atmosphere surrounding
the trial and inflammatory pre-trial
publicity
shepherd was acquitted at a new trial
that year attorney f lee bailey
argued sam shepard's case at the supreme
court
i see vague similarities but certainly
the cases are much more
disparate than they are similar bailly
doubts show then received a fair trial
since the jury was selected in hennepin
county but he says pre-trial publicity
was not the issue the problem with
shoving is the public was being told
if we can get this guy convicted it will
help us with our law enforcement
conflicts around the country which is
nonsense
but i can't imagine that the jurors
didn't have that in mind when they were
being impaneled you better vote guilty
or your next door neighbor might be
throwing paint on your house
bailey does not believe chauvin's case
will go to the supreme court
meanwhile juror brandon mitchell spoke
with law and crime
about the deliberations which he says
lasted about six
hours we were ready for for um for a
guilty verdict
once you walk to the liberation room you
know i thought it would be a quicker
process but there wasn't any
conversation
on you know what's going to happen if we
quit or anything like that
now derek chauvin and the three other
officers charged in george floyd's death
will likely all face federal civil
rights charges the minneapolis star
tribune
is reporting and has been reporting that
there were plans in place had chauvin
been acquitted there were going to be
fbi agents federal agents that went in
placed him under arrest and took him
into custody and the charges would have
been announced immediately
that is actually very similar to what we
were hearing here at law and crime we
were hearing in the weeks before the
trial that had shoved
been convicted or he would be convicted
that there would be
charges announced immediately to ensure
the public that justice was being done
brian thanks internet jeff storms is
back with us he also represents george
floyd's family
jeff personally i don't think the
shepherd case is really close
to the chauvin trial in shepherd for
example the court allowed a temporary
table of 90 reporters
to sit next to the jurors and the
defendant
do you think showman has an argument
here
i really don't you know that the point
that you just made is certainly one of
the
critical distinctions the attorneys in
that case
physically did not have room to access
their own exhibits or have confidential
communications with their clients really
other critical distinctions were the
lack of anonymity for the jurors
the jurors in that case became
celebrities everyone who
knew who they were they were getting
hate mail uh you know they were
forced with the concept that uh you know
their verdict was going to be
known and criticized and individuals in
their community
were going to be able to access them and
you know another critical distinction
was that
the jurors did not receive a very strong
admonition in that case
not to look at the media and and here
that's the complete opposite
the judge was very stern with the jurors
that they were not to look in the media
absolutely no and jeanette so far one
juror who deliberated said
that there was no outside influence but
as we hear from more jurors could there
be a potential
legal issue here for chauvin you know i
think it just depends on if somebody
comes out
one two three jurors and they come out
and say you know i was really fearful of
what was going to happen and i feel
differently you just never know it could
create an issue on appeal and also this
is a much different time than 1954
much different time we have a lot more
media media coming in on our phones
this was a pressure cooker environment
so we really don't know what the jury
was thinking and feeling as they were
deliberating but we may find out in the
weeks ahead
absolutely we have to wait and see as
they come forward thank you both so
ahead on law and crime daily the first
photo of jeffrey epstein's accused
madame behind bars
and it's not a good look but first a
texas family is searching for answers
after their loved one died in police
custody
why the medical examiner is now calling
marvin scott the third's death
a homicide next
welcome back eight people are now under
arrest in connection with an alleged
fraternity hazing incident
stone fultz died three days after being
persuaded to finish an entire bottle of
alcohol
at a phi kappa alpha party officials say
the bowling green state sophomore
was pledging to the fraternity at the
time of the incident
six of the eight were charged with
involuntary manslaughter all eight
indicted are between the ages of 19 and
23 years old
now to texas where the death of a man
who died in police custody
is now being ruled a homicide
marvin scott iii was in colin county
jail for marijuana possession
when he began to behave quote strange
according to collin county sheriff jim
skinner
the sheriff says several officers tried
to restrain scott but the struggle
escalated
the officers reportedly pepper sprayed
scott and placed a spit mask
over his head skinner went on to say
that the 26 year old
became unresponsive scott apparently
received medical attention immediately
but was later pronounced dead the
medical examiner now says scott's death
was caused by a fatal acute stress
response in an individual with
previously diagnosed schizophrenia
during restraint struggle
with law enforcement scott's family was
able to watch several videos of the
detainment
on wednesday and believes he was
suffering from a mental health crisis
marvin scott often used marijuana to
treat his diagnosed schizophrenic
condition
because the meds offered
didn't react well in his system he found
that marijuana smoothed him out for a
bit
if this was a concern at all it was a
mental health concern
seven officers were fired and an eighth
one resigned after scott's death
all right let's bring civil rights
attorney jeff storms back in to discuss
jeff you've obviously been in this
position before you and the family have
seen a video and see something wrong and
the loss of that family member
what is the family of marvin scott iii
and lee merritt going through right now
and could this case affect others like
it
well it's a tremendous amount of pain
initially it's really hard to come to
grips with
seeing the loss of your loved one but
then
when you have the announcement that came
out from the me's office
it's very different than the independent
autopsy that the family commissioned
with
which said it was an asphyxiation death
and it's subtle but it's still
different and so right now a bunch of
the evidence is being withheld and
maintained as private by law enforcement
and you want to begin to be able to get
your narrative out there so people
understand that your loved one
was killed by law enforcement and this
just wasn't an
unfortunate event and do you see
this case being so similar to others
maybe having an effect on other cases as
well
with a fixation by police officers
yeah and the video is going to be really
critical for that brian because
asphyxiation forever caused deaths
in individuals who were restrained by
law enforcement but without the video
we weren't able to prove it and so the
floyd case
showed the world that with really clear
video
proving that a individual was murdered
by law enforcement through asphyxiation
is much easier with that video evidence
absolutely thank you jeff storms
coming up on law and crime daily an
inside look into the suspect's charge
for the death and disappearance of a
georgia beauty queen plus
all's fair in love and car ownership our
preview of the law and crime network's
next gavel gavel trial coverage
you don't want to miss
and now to check in on what's going on
at the law and crime network
jesse webber is here to tell us about
this week's episode on his true crime
show
prime crime hey there brian yeah we're
talking about the unsettling case of
tara grinstead former beauty queen and
teacher who disappeared in 2005.
fast forward over 10 years later we
finally pieced together the story that
involves
two men now we're going to go through
the evidence as well as the incredible
recorded interviews
with law enforcement
he told me that he had gone to her
the issue though is do we really have
the full story as to what happened to
grinstead
and is everyone telling the truth tune
in to long crime
thanks jesse jury selection in the trial
of wisconsin men
charge in a brazen shooting that left
one dead
and two others injured is scheduled for
monday
was it love gone wrong police say joshua
aide was dating his girlfriend
five years before she called it quits in
march 2020.
according to court records text messages
show his ex wanted him to remove
a broken down car from her property
oshkosh police said ade went to the
woman's home
and started shooting her father james
gruntner was shot and killed
the woman and a family friend were also
shot both of them survived
aid is charged with one count of murder
and two counts of attempted murder
he's pleading not guilty and says he was
acting in self-defense
he faces up to life in prison tune in to
law and crime network for capital gavel
coverage
beginning monday here with us again
is civil rights attorney jeff storms and
law and crime reporter
angenette levy anjanet a murder victim
two surviving victims
and these reported text messages does
this look like a strong case for the
prosecution
you know it very well could be depending
on what those text messages
reveal we don't know exactly what all of
them say but keep in mind
he's claiming self-defense so this is
what's called an affirmative defense
meaning
he is going to have to actually prove
that he acted in self-defense however
the burden that he has
is not as strong or as high as the
prosecution's burden so he's planning to
testify
so it depends on really how well he
doesn't understand and
if he is able to explain his actions to
the jury and they believe but with a
preponderance or by
a preponderance of the evidence which
they kind of describe as being like 51
percent or greater than 50 percent
if they believe that he acted in
self-defense and had no other choice
now jeff real quickly self-defense does
that argument make sense to you
or are we missing some facts here well
we certainly need to hear more facts but
it's really hard to understand how it is
that this individual affirmatively went
over
to that home was upset about something
and this shooting uh occurs and that
that's self-defense
it's going to be a little difficult to
believe that yeah
we'll make sure to check this case out
as law and crime is covering it from
capital gavel
when we come back a dog bus in l.a how
the dog napping of lady gaga's pooches
led
to five people being arrested the twists
and charges
after the break
welcome back the first photo of jeffrey
epstein's accused madame behind bars
is now released with a black eye on full
display
gillian maxwell is seen here with a
wrinkly face and a bruise under her eye
the former socialite isn't saying how
her eye became bruised
maxwell's attorneys released a photo and
are claiming she got the shiner from
covering her eyes at night
because the guards do wellness checks on
her every 15 minutes
maxwell is facing six federal charges
including sex trafficking and perjury
harvey weinstein could be extradited to
los angeles in 30 days
the disgraced hollywood mogul will be
facing 11 charges of rape and sexual
assault
upon his arrival in the golden state his
attorneys told a new york judge on
friday
they plan to fight his transfer saying
the former producer
might ask the state's governor to deny
the request a jury convicted weinstein
of rape and sexual assault in new york
last year
he's currently serving a 23-year
sentence
19 kids and counting star josh dugar has
been arrested by federal law enforcement
in arkansas
and is charged with receipt and
possession of child pornography
dugar is pleading not guilty but this is
not the first time the father of six
plus wonderland way has found himself in
trouble with the law
in 2015 he was accused and investigated
in relation to child molestation
dugan's car dealership was rated in a
federal probe in 2019
for unknown reasons dugar is also facing
a civil lawsuit
in connection with real estate fraud
five people have been caught and
arrested in connection with lady gaga's
dog napping
angela levy is back to talk about the
pop star's pooches
yeah brian this is a crazy story three
men have actually been charged with
attempted murder
and armed robbery while two others have
been charged with being accessories to
the crime
you may recall that a man named ryan
fisher was actually
walking lady gaga's dogs they were
french bulldogs
their names gustav and koji and ryan
fisher was actually
shot in this whole ordeal fischer
survived and the frenchies were returned
to the born this way singer
jennifer mcbride she is the
self-proclaimed good samaritan who
returned the dogs
she is now facing charges the lapd
investigated mcbride and found
a dog theft ring while investigating
james jackson
jalen white and lafayette whaley now
face attempted murder and robbery
charges for the theft
mcbride and harold white were also
charged as accessories
the lapd says the thieves wanted the
dogs because of their value
not because they belong to lady gaga
french bulldogs can go for thousands of
dollars on the black market
and police say that four of the suspects
are actually gang members they are all
expected back in court
next month brian thanks aunt jeanette
jeff i know you're a big dog owner just
like myself and angelette's got one as
well
but this dog napping i know in brooklyn
it's you're never going to win a jury
like this in los
angeles i'm assuming it's going to be
the same thing what do you think about
the potential for this being a trial
case
i think there's going to have to be a
plea here everyone loves dogs
and what happened to this poor dog
locker was so tragic
and so i to go to trial on this case i
think would be a probably a losing
proposition
yeah they'd definitely be barking up the
wrong tree there and jeanette
lady gaga was offering a 500 000
reward for her pups but that won't be
paid out right
oh absolutely not you know typically in
these cases brian you get a big reward
like that or any type of reward
when the information leads to the
conviction
of someone involved in the crime in this
case mcbride is accused of being part of
this plot
and someone was shot at ryan fisher was
shot and wounded he could have been
killed and he has
suffered some very serious injuries
because of this whole thing
so there is no way that this reward will
be paid out to her in this case
maybe there's somebody else we don't
know about that provided some
information but it's definitely not
mcbride yeah it's also gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out
maybe this expands to other charges
because like you said there was a dog
napping ring
jeff and jeanette thank you for joining
us here today and thank you for joining
us here on the law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
you